esteban salazar que más nos puede contar
sobre toda esta polémica que se ha
agudizado especialmente en los últimos
días previos a las elecciones
estas elecciones son unas elecciones
históricas es la oportunidad por primera
vez de que s millones de víctimas de
este país puedan tener una
representación dentro de la cámara de
representantes- en 16 curules un millón
156 mil personas que conforman parte de
los 167 municipios tuvieron la
oportunidad hoy de poder participar con
dos grandes obstáculos importantes por
un lado por parte de la
institucionalidad no se garantizó por
medio del órgano electoral que se
pudiera dar los recursos para hacer
campañas los anticipos para que varias
organizaciones y varios de sus
candidatos pudieran ejercer el tema de
la campaña política para buscar votos
teniendo en cuenta que se trata de unos
municipios con un nivel de dispersión
bastante alto en la ruralidad donde
tienen que caminar bastante donde hay
una lógica de un transporte fluvial
bastante costoso y una segunda barrera
es importante también y está relacionada
con la presencia de estructuras armadas
ilegales dentro de las cuales nosotros
desde la fundación paz y reconciliación
en los 167 municipios identificamos la
presencia de una de ellas por lo menos
en
138 en 90 municipios de presencia de las
estructuras de clan del golfo en 73 de
las disidencias y en 70 de la ln esto
dificulta de cualquier manera que se
pudiera hacer campaña electoral y
finalmente cierro con un análisis
bastante importante y es que no
solamente se trata de los riesgos a
nivel institucional y de orden público
sino que también nosotros visualizamos
unos riesgos relacionados con partidos
políticos tradicionales y con clanes
políticos que buscarían cooptar estas
circunscripciones de paz toda vez que se
necesitan menos votos y toda vez que hay
más dificultades para que se pueda
competir en un escenario que realmente
garantice que las personas que quieren
participar dentro de este escenario
representan fielmente a las víctimas
hemos visto algunos departamentos que
hemos señalado también de nuestros
informes hacia la zona del norte de
santander hacia la zona del sur de
córdoba hacia la zona de la
circunscripción que comprende los
departamentos de la guajira
magdalena y cesar en donde incluso en
este momento está participando como
candidato el hijo de el ex paramilitar
jorge 40 que no ha respondido en
absoluto a la justicia colombiana se
encuentra extraditado en estos momentos
en los eeuu tenemos varios ejemplos
sobre los hechos relacionados también
con violencia política y electoral el
día de ayer y antier registramos que
hubo dos personas amenazadas hacia las
circunscripciones que comprenden el
urabá y el bajo cauca antioqueño y
también vimos amenazas en la semana
pasada por parte de los candidatos en el
departamento del norte de santander